on vous en a abondamment parlé ici à
cette émission
le dilemme de québec il se donne le
gouvernement ici pour décider si ça sera
des autobus ou un train léger ultime
mans sur le futur pont champlain est
bien ottawa on avait un peu un dilemme
semblable est ce qu'on allait poursuivre
la croissance du transport en commun
avec les autobus des voies réservées
là-bas ou opter graduellement pour le
train léger
on a choisi ottawa le train léger
jean-sébastien cloutier tarifs
attractifs voit la ville d'ottawa n'a
pas de métro mais elle a un bon réseau
d'autobus
le coeur de ce réseau et le transitway
un service rapide qui relie les
banlieues proches au centre ville sur 35
km de voies réservées le transitway a vu
le jour en 1983 et a été complété en 96
au coût de 420 millions de dollars
les autobus desservent une quarantaine
de stations dont certaines sont des
plaques tournantes comme ici à l'est du
centre-ville
à l'heure de pointe les autobus son pare
chocs contre pare chocs et les usagers
n'ont pas trop à attendre
de façon générale le transitway est
apprécié le fait que le système soit
pause sur l'airé principale évite
beaucoup trafic dense et très rapide
voilà effectivement le gros avantage du
service rapide d'ottawa la majeure
partie du parcours des autobus se fait
en voie propre complètement à l'écart de
la circulation automobile
un avantage que montréal n'a pas dans
laxe pont champlain centre ville à
ottawa le transitway a même été planifié
pour accueillir un très léger nous dit
le directeur général de la société de
transport de la ville
quand tu fais un système de transport en
commun ses propres nécessairement
seulement pour aujourd'hui c'est pour le
futur et si tu prends ce futur et tu
prends le longview et des dents
des sessions avec en moyenne 240 mille
passagers chaque semaine le réseau
d'autobus rapides d'ottawa et le plus
utilisé en amérique du nord près de la
moitié de ses 900 40 autobus sont soit
des autobus articulés ou deux
mais à deux étages bref le temps était
venu selon la ville de pas ses oreilles
surtout pour centre ville sur les
quelques kilomètres où les autobus
côtoient les voitures la circulation est
devenue trop lourde
une situation qui rappelle celle vécue à
montréal près de la gare centrale vers
deux points on peut pas pousser plus
d'autobus
ottawa aura donc son train léger en 2018
un projet de 2,1 milliards de dollars la
ligne de la confédération comme on
l'appelle aura 13 kilomètres d'est en
ouest et empruntera le tracé d'une des
lignes d'autobus du transitway le projet
comprend treize stations et le tunnel de
deux kilomètres et demi pour libérer les
rues du centre-ville
la construction du tunnel est d'ailleurs
bien commencé
c'est le plus gros projet de la baudroie
en coopération l'autre chose c'est le
riz local et ça va faire la fondation
pour le système transport comme le futur
contrairement à la mt qui propose un
salaire plus près du train que du
tramway pour le futur pont champlain
ottawa a plutôt choisi le tram-train
plus léger et moins cher il s'intègre à
la circulation en ville
mais peut aussi accélérer jusqu'à 100
kilomètres heure lorsqu'il en sort c'est
alstom qui construira le tri d'ottawa
une technologie très un usage ailleurs
dans le monde
c'est un mode qui utilisent le tram en
région urbaine et le train pour
rejoindre la périphérie où les banlieues
autre matière à réflexion pour montréal
le délai relativement court pour
réaliser le projet d'ottawa consultation
publique et recommandations en 2009
approbation par le conseil municipal en
2010 signature de ppp en 2012 puis début
des travaux d'une durée de cinq ans en
2013 avec son train la ville compte
attirer de nouveaux développements
autour des gares
à court terme le train train pourra
transporter dix mille 700 passagers à
l'heure dans chaque direction notamment
servir aux besoins de conduire c'est moi
qui ai lancé moi je vois comme quelque
chose de nécessaire une ville va
toujours bossé donc il faut avoir une
infrastructure qui va soutenir les
utilisateurs à qui nous avons parlé
étaient contents de voir leur taxe
dépensés pour un train léger
contrairement au projet sur chantier ou
québec devrait assumer toute la facture
la ville d'ottawa elle financera près de
la moitié de son projet le reste étant
assumé par l'ontario et le fédéral à
terme dits la ville le très léger et
coûtera moins cher que les autobus
on a calculé qu'en banner et qu'en mai 1
16 million $ par année avec 7 projets en
coûts d'exploitation exactement les
systèmes dont on parle aussi de 30 ans
la durée de vie de 40 dont vous allez
remplacer trois caps fois les bus pour
le même temps que vous allez avoir
investi dans la formule du slr donc
c'est une chose soit on regarde à court
terme on regarde pas longtemps il y a
donc matière à réflexion pour le
ministère des transports du québec
jean-sébastien vous dites plus légers
enfin votre interviewé du plus léger
moins cher le tram train
pourquoi est ce qu on n'y a pas pensé ou
est ce qu'on devrait y penser pour le
futur pont champlain
alors effectivement la question se pose
parce que jusqu'ici vous l'avez
probablement vu la mt semble préférer un
système de train léger plus lourd si je
peux me permettre un peu comme le skate
canada à vancouver avec la majeure
partie des rails en voie aérienne avec
des infrastructures plus lourde
également les stations on a posé la
question à mt donc aujourd'hui ce que ce
sera envisageable un tram train à
montréal la seule réponse qu'on obtenu a
été un courriel plutôt laconique où on
nous disait qu'on était toujours à
déterminer à évaluer les meilleures
options possibles pour 2015 qui est sûr
en tout cas c'est que le p dg d'alstom
canada monsieur gothique vous voyez dans
le reportage lui il pense que ce serait
une bonne idée que ce tramway à montréal
bon c'est sûr elle n'est pas ottawa est
ce que ce serait une bonne idée à
brossard après de la glisse au centre
ville ouest de montréal où déjà il ya
plus beaucoup d' espace donc d'avoir ce
tramway à la hauteur des voitures
certains vont peut-être en douter lui en
tout cas n'en doute pas je vous laisse
écouter pour le pont champlain
c'est une formule qui serait très bonne
passe que les passagers pourraient
embarquer à divers endroits dans la
ville et à ce moment là le tram
prendrait la forme ultra travers
serais-je qu'elle 100 kilomètres heure
le pont champlain où la rivière pourrait
les en banlieue sur la rive-sud qui
reprendra ce moment là aussi la formule
du tram
bien sûr que monsieur 20 ces équipements
et et sa salade mais ça fera partie de
la discussion publique au cours des
prochains mois mais même à ottawa cet
intéressant parce qu'il ya des députés
provinciaux conservateur qui disent on
installa ça coûte de l'argent tout ça
voilà ce dont je parlais dans mon
reportage c'était la phase 1 il ya une
phase 2 qui est déjà sur la table qui
coûterait 3 milliards de dollars dont 1
milliard qui serait financée par le
gouvernement ontarien et l'actuel
candidat conservateur dans cette
élection dont
qui se tiendra jeudi tim hudak a déjà
dit que s'il était élu jeudi il n'était
pas question pour la province de
financer le train léger d'ottawa
la deuxième partie de ce très léger
parce que c'était trop cher alors bref
ces débats sur les finances publiques et
sur le train ou les autobus
il y en a chez nos voisins ou si
l'argent ne pousse pas dans les arbres
voilà merci jean sébastien roy